大家好我叫文杰我是一个来自自业跳动的一个前辆工程师然后最近呢也是移动这边有一些邀请嘛然后我刚好也写了一本比较简单的小册技术小册然后决定小册然后所以就这过程的时候挺痛苦的花了很长时间去看圆码
然后看完之后也觉得这个东西怎么那么复杂所以有一些方式方法技巧可以分享给大家吧就在这看的过程中反正这个过程很累啊然后所以如果你有需要你刚好有需要可以听一听希望能帮助到大家然后这PPT呢是我时间参数准备的不是特别好大家见底预期啊
就直接捞干货就可以了OK 那我们就开始吧我叫文杰然后这左边的是我刚写完的一本决定的小册其实内容也不是特别复杂我觉得还是挺容易看懂的容易上手然后另外我关于我自己的话我是文杰然后我是来自广东上尾然后我特别喜欢吃盘蟹特别是地网蟹如果要请我吃饭就请我吃盘蟹吧然后最好是地网蟹
然后其次的话我现在正在那个自己跳动的飞书前端团队然后其他就不用介绍了如果有兴趣可以扫右边的这个二维码关注我的公众号然后时不时的会发一些内容吧对 OK然后其次是关于今天的内容前面说这么多终于进入主题了为什么要讲这一块在我看来
WiPad虽然现在其实有特别多的这种类似的框架包括Vit包括Prepare或者乱七八糟的SnowPad乱七八糟的P大堆或者SWC之类的OK 这是一个特别好的现象这个现象就证明这个前端的工程化领域其实还是有很大的承载空间的然后也还是有人愿意投入到这个空间因为它本来就需要是一个
是一个干区那在这一个干区的领域里面其实Wechat算是一个比较多年的对就从他出生到现在经历了五个大版本的迭代然后慢慢的算是现在还算是这个领域里面的龙头老大可能这么说吧就这样一个地位虽然现在已经有很多新的技术在跳起来做得特别好的Anyway
anyway 就是所以我依然觉得wipad是一个至少在短期内还是三五年内可能还是一个挺值得去学习的方向那我们学这个东西有什么作用呢这你就举了几个例子包括说现在很多公式的工程化基础设施其实都是基础wipad去实现的那说白了可能就做一个壳然后把wipad包进去然后里面包含了一大堆的插件
或者一大堆的loader等等等等又或者是有异性的场景可能用webpack可能会更合适原说小程序小程序是中国特产的然后现在如果你要去你放眼整个行业去看的话可能大部分的这种小程序的预编一款价都会是用webpack写的对等等等等所以整体它的稳定性啊它功能性兼容性可能都会比较强但是但是啊
但是大部分人其实都不会用包括我自己在以前没有没有没有专心去写这本书之前可能都不是特别会用为什么不会用呢那有很多原因就anyway就导致了我其实都不太懂到底要去怎么写一个查件或者是写一个loader反正写的很不好所以我就所以究其根本的原因就在于可能这社区没有
特别好的资料或者没有特别好的学习方法或者没有经验分享资料或者外配本身就特别复杂导致这个东西很多人都不太会所以我写了一本书写完之后我觉得受人与余不如受人与余我普通话不太好啊anyway就是这个意思就随我把我的一些学习的经验想分享一下ok然后这这一页就挑过吧然后ok
这一页就是说Wavet很复杂确实很复杂这里面有很多代码这是我拉了最新的Wavet的常库里面的代码下来之后看了一下最终统计下来所有的代码加起来大概有八万多哈
八万多韩带嘛这在前端来说已经算是一个特别大的一个特别盘大的一个项目然后而且它不是普通的这种页面的CORD而是它有比较复杂的架构这架构里面有无数的各种各样的乱七八糟你看也不知道它是干嘛的一个类型如果你没有深入的去了解的话可能这些都会是一个比较平紧的东西吧对然后哎
怎么跳了下去所以这一件事情的难度还是比较大的如果你需要去做你需要去学我觉得可以认真的听一听就包括说我今天准备分享的内容就包括说整个WiPad的原码结构的一个出略的
介绍以及一些出略的调试技巧因为时间关系不会说得特别深其次的话可能重点还是放在这个整个webpad的构建的主流程里面可能重点还是会在这一块以及最终有一些比较通用的原代码学习的阅读的一些技巧这就是今天要分享的内容OK我们先从这个webpad的代码结构开始
这是比较重要的几个目录先不看它是干嘛的我们先来看一下我这里大家可以看得清楚吗然后已经把代码拉下来了拉下来之后第一眼可以看到这里面有非常非常多的目录结构还有非常非常多的文件这里面有特别复杂那特别复杂里面有哪些是重要的呢其实我觉得就两个东西比较重要
一个是Library这类目录所有的Web带码全部都在这目录底下其次的话第二个重要的点是在这个PackageDensation这些带码的应该都知道这个文件是干什么的ok然后其次的话就是Library目录底下会有一个Web带
点在这个文件它的逻辑其实不是特别复杂也就两百韩代码这两百韩代码你可以理解为它就是整个WebPad的入口文件这个入口文件里面可能它底层还会有很复杂的东西但是这就我们要去看代码的时候就得从这里开始ok然后所以这就是比较重要的几个目录几个文件一个是这个Lib目录你就
大部分的精力就关注在这里就行了其他的什么benchmark或者examples或者decoration如果你是刚开始看的话可能都不是特别重要可以先忽略其次的话在这个lib里面会有这三个文件是比较重要的一个是webpack刚刚我们说来是所有事情的入口其次的话是一个compilercompiler.js这一个是干什么呢我们等一下会说在其次的话有一个compilation
点JS也是等下会说这三个文件如果是你第一次接触刚开始准备去看Webpad代码的话那是最高由需要去关注的一个入口文件ok然后再其次的话我们对前面一趴就结束了这是我们现在需要了解的内容
它的重点就在有若干的文件是现在就需要去关注的然后就没有了那接下来我们就调试起来把这个环境运行起来那要怎么运行起来呢就怎么把我们clone下来的这一份web的代码运行起来呢有这么几行命令第一是装一个global的全局装一个ndbe的工具ndbe是一个
我个人特别喜欢然后比较简单易用的然后迁移性 肯用性特别强的一个本地的调试工具Notice程序的调试工具OK 我们先把它装下来装下来之后呢我们需要创建一个调试的项目说白了就是用webpad的一个项目那我这边也提前准备好了就是我现在达了一个这个简单的一个一个前端项目
在这个项目里面会有一个webhat.config.s的文件这个文件那就是webhat的配置文件在其次的话会有一个src里面有一个index文件这也就是唯一的一个代码内容OK 所以是一个很简单的代码那我们接下来要做的事情OK 这第二步就是一个调试项目一个简单 越简单越好啊我们现在就让这个程序让webhat跑起来就行了
然后第三步需要做的一件事情就是把webpad这一个代码副本就是我们clone下来的这一个包 这一个包给执行一下那个mpnlinkok 那老师姐应该都知道这这个命令是干嘛的然后在之后可以在webpad的原代码里面你觉得需要去调试的地方
加入这个debug余句我其实为了准备这个ptt我也提前写了就比如说我现在在整个应用的整个webpack的入口入口函数这里加了一个debug余句ok 加进去之后呢在另外少了一步就在我们的调试项目里面去再次行一次这个ambient linkwebpack把这个webpack给link过来ok 然后现在我们就可以用这个调试miniindb
nps webpackOK然后就会打开一个调试器重新再来这是很正常的一个线线ndb竞产崩溃又崩了不好意思稍等一下为什么三星温柔看一下啊OK经过前面有一些波折有一些翻车但是这翻车也不是我写的代码所以我也没办法
anyway就是我们进入了一个调试模式这个调试模式就是我们现在运行的就是大家可以看到就是webpad的一个入口函数的代码我们在这个代码里面就可以开始去分析接下来流程是怎么走的比如说我现在就要分析这个入口函数为什么是从入口函数开始呢这里插一句就你要去学任何的
这种前端的宽价无论是reactor还是view还是还是还是那个其他包括vscode那我觉得都有几件事情就你在刚开始学它的原代码的时候你不要很干的去仔细看而是要想办法解决几个问题一个是你要学会调试它比如说我刚刚带大家走了这一步就是让大家能在本地
调试起这个WiPad的原代码对吧这是第一步只有这一步你掌握了之后你才能接下来比较自如的你需要在任何地方插入一个断点然后断点调试去看每一行代码的执行逻辑每一个变连的状态流转你都需要这个能力所以我们花了一点时间来讲这个这第一步第二步是入口我们通常
去分析一个项目的时候去看原代码的时候你可能敢拉下来看到的所有东西都是很陌生那这时候你需要做的事情就是分析出来到底哪一块是所有程序的那个启动的点那也就是所谓的函数当然是入口函数了这里就是你要做的所有事情的开始的点所以通常都需要先认清楚哪一块是入口函数
ok这罗里巴说又说了几句啊anyway就我们先来进入了webpad的入口在这个入口里面可以看到他做的事情我的代码ok这入口我先来调小一点在这个入口里面这是我刚插入的锻炼语句然后马上创建一个create的匿名函数这匿名函数是干什么的我们不用管 现在不用管
因为它只是创建了一个函数它还没有掉然后接下来看如果有callback如果没有callback又是什么情况这看起来好像也不是很重要那我们就当作没有callback的场景因为我们大部分用的时候除非你自己去封装它要不然都是没有callback的场景那我们就看大部分可能会出现的一个场景比如说这个这个里面就开始这个函数里面就开始去调用这个create函数
所以這個Create函數應該就是一個非常重要的函數那接下來他做的事情然後在這裡判斷一下這個Obsense這個Obsense也就擅長傳進來的這個Obsense它有可能是一個數組也有可能是一個當力的一個對象
那如果不是数组的话它会走下面的这一段逻辑那我们在应用的时候可能大部分或者我们现在这个demo的场景下就是一个普通的对象普通对象的情况下那它应该走的就是下面这一段逻辑OK然后紧接着就开始去调这个create compiler这个create compiler又干了什么呢一堆的逻辑最终会new一个这个compiler的对象我刚才干什么呢
我刚才在做的一件事情就分析它的主流程如果我们在看代码的时候包括WarePad的代码它很复杂至少对我来说很复杂所以对我来说我去看它的时候我是没有心思没有余力去关注一些分支逻辑的现在对我来说我最重要的就是看懂它的主干逻辑
那我们刚刚看到的就是各种判断断条件下去看一下这个判断条件我是大部分情况下都命中这个场景还是大部分情况下都不命中这个场景对吧按照这一个逻辑一路履下来然后就可以找到关键的那几个步骤那不关键的像这个条件判断或者是分子逻辑或者是这种属性的
就变念的变化之类的那我现在都不用关注我现在要做的就把这若干的步骤一二三四的步骤我这里就有标记出来了这一二三四的步骤给标记出来然后化成一个化成一个流程图ok那我就是我在平常在看代码的时候所做的一件事情说白了就是
我们回顾一下刚刚做的事情就是看主干逻辑然后忽略现在去忽略所有的分子逻辑所有的不必要的我现在不需要关注的父子与之之也好其他乱七八糟的代码也好anyway我就是只看主干最终就可以看出这一条脉络那这一条脉络刚刚我们就看到分析到了这一个create compiler这create compiler
里面呢又可以继续往下它继续往下做了一堆的事情包括这里用了这个plugin然后出实化这一堆的变略然后再return一个compilerOK 到这里结束了所以这就是真的就像它的名字一样它只是create但是还没有触发变异那我们又回逻逻辑又可以回到这个compiler也就是这个create这里
然后可以看到create它做的事情也是一路的把这compiler创建出来之后的compiler给返回到上一集也就是外层的这一套函数里面然后外层的这一套函数里面在这里最终我create出来之后的compiler我们到这里也可以理解一个点
create只是创建了这实力还没有真正去做任何的事情接下来它就开始执行如果是watch的话就掉watch函数如果是那个普通的编译的话就掉这个编译函数runok 到这里这就是重点了我们也可以继续忽略这个watch而是关注这个run因为我们现在的视力是最简单的视力最简单的视力的情况下走的就是这个run逻辑
OK我们直接进来看吧这里create出来之后在OK然后就走到了因为这个watch是force所以会走到这个compiler.run的函数那我们就继续往下走来逻辑接下来继续往下走就到了这个compiler.js里面然后我们直接也可以开始直接找这个compiler.run
韩束 这韩束里面也会有一堆乱七八糟前面这些都是控制的叉叉等于叉叉这一堆逻辑我现在都不用管包括这RUN我也不用管然后直接看它的主干逻辑主干逻辑里面有一个IDLE应该也不是什么重要的东西那直接看这个RUN也就是说这RUN韩束最终会执行这一个RUN然后里面会有Hawk这Hawk就很坑爹OKanyway就最终
经过一堆的hawk的执行之后最终会调用这个compiler点compiler的谈数ok这这一套流程继续这样吕下来我们可以讲一个小时可以讲一个晚上所以我们就跳过吧然后最终我按照刚刚的逻辑我按照刚刚的方法把一些不必要的东西全部无列的只看主干逻辑最终就可以梳理出来这一条
这一条执行流程在这一条执行流程里面大家可以照着这个图去翻一下这代码就会一路一路的New Compiler然后Init然后BlaBlaBlaBla然后会有一个Compiler Run然后Compiler Compiler就刚刚我们看到的那一行代码大家睡着了吗我要睡着
这张图可以照着去看然后最终关键点就在于最终会创建多一个combination这下面是combination大家我这里写错了稍等我把这个这是一个combination时间关系所以我刚刚就说了有点粗糙anyway就创建出来一个combination之后
会去执行这个compiler.hoc应该是compilation.hoc.mac.core也就是说会执行一个非常重要的钩子词词在compiler里面这个hoc.mac.hoc对是这compiler里面会去触发一个mac的钩子然后这mac的钩子呢会开始真正的去执行代码
为什么我知道它这里会开始真正的执行代码因为我已经把后面的东西都看完了所以我是很明确地知道这件事情如果你们有兴趣我也可以把这些标注过的这些这些片段发给大家或者是同步到某一个git上面把一些重要的标注都标注上去ok anyway 我们回到这里这里的重点就是经过前面的一堆的电源流程之后我们进入到一个非常重要的这一个
compiler.hoc.mac的调用这一个调用非常重要因为接下来的阶段接下来的事情就是通过它来做的那问题就是在于接下来的流程我没办法再像刚刚一样去分析说我这里面调用了什么函数然后直接分析出来一些东西对吧那怎么办呢因为这一段逻辑已经被
wifi的钩子给封装起来了所以我接下来要教的另外一个办法另外一个重点就在于怎么分析这一部分被hoc封装起来的代码为了学会分析这件事情你得先了解一下什么叫hoc是干嘛的在wifi里面大家应该用过的都知道wifi有一个叫
把这种基于tapable的一个hoc的插件架构位外的插件很强这插件简单的总结就是会有hoc这个实体的存在而这一个实体的作用就在于右手边的这三个步骤webpad在购建过程在执行过程的不同的时间节点不同的阶段会触发不同的钩子这第一个重点
稍等一下OK 第一个重点就在实际第二个重点 比如说我们现在看到的MAC它就是在Compiler它启动之后马上执行这个Compiler函数的时候去触发这个MAC BOLD这就触发了实际 这个很重要你在学问
或者你要写那个插件的时候你的都得非常关注这一个点其次是每个钩子都会传递不同的上下文参数也就是我现在这一段这个compiler我们再怎么去消费这个这个这个hook呢就是这一段代码类似的就是一个compiler.hooks.max.tap又很长
总之重点就在这个tab函数然后tab函数之后你陪在tab函数里面去注册一个回调那下次webpad它触发这个钩子的时候就会执行你这个回调执行的时候会首先传过来一个三下文参数不同的钩子会有不同的三下文参数我们要去跟这个hawk跟webpad产生交互的时候要去修改hawk的状态的时候就得通过这个三下文参数去执行
去修改善良文参数的状态或者是调用善良文参数的函数就比如说比如说有一个entry 内部有很多的插件那其中有一个叫entry的插件这entry的插件里面呢它就会用到这张mac我为什么会知道它是entry用到呢因为我直接就在这里面用这个hocus.mapmac
点tab这样的方式在wipad的代码里面大部分的你要分析一个hocus在什么地方被用到的时候你都可以用这种方式就是全名hocus.tab因为可以说这是wipad内部的一个编码规范吧它都会这么写基本上然后我就
用这个tab 用这个mac的钩子可以找到在这一层地方被用到然后包括这个dll entry那我一看名字我就知道我这个东西是用来做那个webpad的dll特性的然后或者是dynamic entry那是动态的入口那我现在要分析的是一个静态入口是最简单的场景我就不看这个了我继续往下看会看到一个entry
这个entry看起来就是静态入口的意思那我们进来看到可以看到它做的事情其实也很简单就是compiler.addentry也还是在这里加一个debug吧因为我们现在猜测猜测就是那个在entryplugin里面会去调整compilation.addentry去触发一个构建OK我们刚刚加了这个debug然后
取消掉然后重新执行不知道会不会奔很顺利好我们现在就进来了然后这里还是入口入口我们就直接跳过然后就可以看到他已经进来了这个entry plug-in的这个hawk mac的回调里面了然后在回调里面他只做了一件事情就是combination and add entry然后就没有了
那接下来的逻辑就很简单我们就继续看这个Adentrate它做的事情可以看到它也是一堆乱七八糟的东西就是先出实话一个Obsence然后再调这个AdentrateItem这里的逻辑就是Wechat一个过渡设计的地方了你再如果你自己去看Wechat的代码你会发现它有很多
明明可以很简单的它非得写成很绕的很多次的函数的调用就比如说我现在要演示的它首先会调这个AddEntryItem然后会出发这个也不重要重要的是接下来会调这个AddModeralTrade然后把这个Entry的dependence其实它就有一个Entry对象给加入到这个ModeralTrade里面
然后在modular tray addmodular tray addmodular tray在这里在这里又会有一堆的逻辑包括说去创建一个factory这个也很重要啊modular点这个factory其实还挺重要的但是我们就不展开去剪的然后接下来等到我创建出一个factory之后又再继续调用这个handle我为什么点不开
我的vscode的词我电脑性能不太好所以偶尔会比较比较那个啥anyway不用看接下来这展开之后的代码重点在于我们继续看一下这个modular entryhandlemodular creation然后在这个creation里面他做的事情用继续往下factor all就一直往下一直往下一直往下一直往下
对 这就我会拍一个比较坑爹的点他会把一件事情拆得很细然后逻辑上会一直往下很多层你就怎么办呢就是就只能干你就只能忙你就只能我遮寒树我一直追踪下去这主干用的逻辑一直追踪下去然后不断的往下看
这一个函数做了什么事情然后它内部又掉了另外一个什么函数然后一直往下然后不断的去判断不断的去调试去加debug语句这里很重要去加这个debug语句然后为什么要加这个就为了能进入这段点调试不断的在你觉得重要的地方去加这个debug语句然后调试起来
调试了调试进去之后再去验证一下去猜想去验证一下你对这一段代码的一个猜想就比如说我们看到我们看到简单说啊比如说我们看到这一段代码我们不知道他是干什么的哎那进来进来进来进来看一下哎factory module然后它里面是factory这个factory就是三上面我们前面说的比较重要的一个对象
factory里面又去create完了之后又不了吧那我们就猜测这个factory应该是一个比频道重要的对象我们又可以继续玩里面走然后那就不断的去现在还断掉了因为玩里面走之后是一个抽象函数你没有逻辑的抽象函数你又得去调试起来去看一下这个factory具体是哪一个具体的类型对anyway
重点就在于这过程没有什么技巧日拱异族真的就是一步一步的每一个函数往里面走一个函数一个函数的往里面走然后每走进一个函数之后你就去看这一个函数的代码你不用看得很复杂不用看得很细还是前面说的逻辑主干逻辑还是关注主干什么是主干 什么不是主干
那你就得调试起来你就得加这个debug语句然后锻炼调试进去看这一段代码做了什么事情产生了什么付出用然后去验证你的猜险然后并且这过程会不断的不断的重复不断的重复我就是当时我当时就是这么过来的当时就现在想想很多
反正很累了然后所以我这里就分享一些快捷的方法吧比如说那我们是不是可以补充一些背景知识就比如说刚刚说的这一套从那个启动就是这个wifi启动一直到它开始vac一直到它开始去创建那个modular factory
然后再通过Factory去创造一个modular然后这一套流程就是一步一步地做然后我做完之后呢我总结了这样一份一个一个一个文章然后这文章里面呢虽然一年多之前写的然后还字还挺多的但是呢重点在于这几张图我把这几张图都放出来了就如果你要去学微费的代码
那你就可以关注这几个图我现在没办法把这图翻大这pt的模块有点问题然后回头我把这pt发出来大家再去看这几个重点的步骤吧在重点步骤里面我把一型关键的函数都标出来然后以及每一个函数的作用我都有在文章里面总结这一篇文章在我公众号上面有大家也得自己去看然后
这一个流程过来之后那这就是它的构建组流程你就可以对着这一个图一个函数一个函数的去看然后沿着这一条路径去往下排查往下分析往下去debug来验证说这篇文章里面是不是在乱七八糟乱说还是说真的是这篇文章说的是没错的还是怎么样的对 就可以沿着这一个图
很建議大家沿著這一個圖一路的去看所以這就是我所能提供的一個算是假帶了私貨的一個捷徑再其次的話我還可以提供另外一個信息就是在你看代碼的過程中我們前面蘿莉巴說了一堆都是具體的技巧那具體的技巧最終推斷出來了一個結論就是
这件事情很麻烦所以我就proposal这篇文章这篇读大家可以去看一下其中要特别关注的其实是在于这个构建的主流程我喝口水口渴然后在这个构建主流程里面它从开始一直到前面的一堆的初始化一直到构建阶段然后就其实我我个人是把它分成这三个阶段一个是初始化
就还比较简单做事情比较少这一块应该是软骨骨头可以随便看一看就知道了不是重点然后其次的话是构建阶段这个那构建阶段做了什么事情呢它就是很重要的可以理解为专门处理输入的一个一大段一大坨逻辑在这个逻辑里面呢
重点就在从entry开始也就是从我们配置的入口文件开始你配置的几个入口就有几个entry从这入口文件开始去帝规的去找出所有的依赖模块然后找出依赖的依赖然后一直到整个项目的所有的资源全部都找出来之后构建一个模块依赖关系图那这一个模块依赖关系图是什么呢
也可以去放一下我工作号里面的文章有介绍的然后再其次是最后的生成阶段我们前面说了这个构成阶段它要解决的问题就在于处理输入可以简单理解为处理输入把所有的modular所有的文件全部读进来处理一遍那封砖和生成这一个阶段它要做的事情就是把前面给找出来的所有模块所有modular对象
一个逐个逐个的封砖进不同的trunk对象里面这个trunk的逻辑这个封砖的逻辑其实还挺复杂的但是大家可以简单理解为他就是把这些modular全部在合并在一起合并完了之后这一个一个的trunk在作为一个文件输出出去所以最终就能达到一个我可能有100个模块就是100个圆码文件最终能合并成一个圆码文件的这样的一个效果对吧
这就是主流程这主流程你一旦理解了它非常重要你一旦理解了之后你可以说是现在以百分之七八十的需要了解的知识都掌握到了其他的都是细致末节比如说怎么实现一个HMR怎么实现Trade Shacking怎么实现BlaBlaWatchCatch之类的东西都是次要的分支逻辑那如果我们要去学我们肯定一定
那就稍微也别那么疑定了就推荐大家从这组流程开始吧分为这几个阶段ok然后在构建阶段呢他要做的事情就是从hawks这个hawk开始然后去去去blahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahblahbl
都已经画出来了大家就照着这张图走一遍然后然后不是单纯的不是单纯的看这张图就可以了我建议就是按照我前面推荐了这种debug的方法把你的代码调试起来让它运行起来然后找到这上面列的每一个函数比如说这个这个Jawskriepaster这一个东西的这个pass函数找到它然后
插进一个debug余句然后看一下他接下来做的一些事情是怎么样的是真的按照这个逻辑去走吗还是怎么样的不啦不啦然后用这一个来验证然后这是类似有点像是一个股价但是这个股价呢也只能让你知道是这么一件事情里面的很多肉块还是得你自己去补充但是至少这个股价给到大家一个怎么说呢
以所引的作用然后就不嫌弃讲里面的具体过程几次的话cl就封装阶段前面说的封装阶段我也列出来了大家可以自己去翻公动号吧我就不一个一个讲了就时间关系anyway它就是从这一个入口函数开始cl阶段是从commodation的cl函数开始这个函数大家也可以来看一下
我当时真的是C2就是我们来看一下它有这么多含带嘛就大概300多含带嘛一个函数里面有300多含带嘛然后这300多含带嘛里面基本上每一个都挺重要的而且中间有一堆的hocs每一个hocs到底是干嘛的一开始我都不知道就特别复杂你现在我们看到的都是这一个C2的函数
然后最终会进入到这个优化吹然后最终又怎么怎么样的这个函数本身挺复杂的然后我也把关键的流程比较关键的步骤也给梳理出来了大家按照这个步骤去看就行了步骤的过程中首先前面会去处理这个Trunk包括我按照逻辑按照规则去封锻出不同的Trunk不同的Module
发行不同的创改里面以及最终我这个创改也都生成完了之后再去调用一个code generationcode generation它的作用就是生成最终的代码然后等等就在这一张图里面都有了我就不展开讲了还是那句话虽然说的有点水但是重点在于这张图我说再多也现在这个场合可能意义不大大家就去看图吧
按照这单图的股落卖落去梳理吧去看吧然后总之这件事情如果你要去学外配的代码前面我们也说这件事情是有价值的只是说这价值可能可能跟对每一个人都不太一样吧但是对我来说我觉得是挺的价值的所以我去梳理了挺多文章的大家也可以去看一下都在公送大部分的文章
很多在公众号里面对然后然后我们再给大家换一下并吧呃你一旦学会了一旦学会了这个这个这个这个微博的员嘛我或者我们先总结一下我们前面到底聊了什么乱七八糟了就挺散的但是有一条一线主线的或者说可以总结一些东西包括说我在看代码的时候我关注主干逻辑我不去
我现在不去关注一些不太重要的分支逻辑有一些可以跳过代码 尽量先跳过以及不断的插入debar的语句不断的断点调试让这件事情跑起来跑起来之后再去观察逻辑流转再去观察那个那个状态变更每一个动作每一个语句他所带来的副作用都可以去观察
这就是具体的你要看一些具体代码的时候的技巧其次的话如果是外派的话你可以沿着前面介绍的这几个思路这几个关键流程把主干给梳理清楚给看清楚可能这过程你需要花一点时间一个月两个月之后你就会我觉得还是挺有收获的对之后你就可以你化病了包括你可以不要
舒服的比较自在的去写一些插件还有loader或者是你遇到webpad的问题构建的问题车可以马上反映过来哦这应该是哪个地方出问题啊对然后要怎么怎么解决哦这个又又是错别字哦回头我再改一下好吧对不起然后其次的话就是啊你可以有能力去做一些基建的事情就每家公司我见到很多公司其实都需要这种
这种内部的一些急建项目吧 工程化的项目所以你学完之后很多同学会说我一直在做业务但是我理解如果你具备这能力的话你是有能力去你是有机会去争取这种更底层更急建的一些事情来做的然后再其次的话可以去优化这个那个构建性能这就十打十的
可能随时都能用上再其次的话这件事情很复杂那你把这么复杂事情给解决了学会了你就可以有比较强的这种学习能力对OK等等等等就反正画了一个饼我还是挺建议大家如果有需要或者是对这方面比较感兴趣或者是怎么样的都去看一看再其次
我最后这是最后一趴了时间时间就挺有限的我就尽快讲吧这是最后一趴大家没有睡着吧接下来没那么干了也不会说像上数学课了希望大家醒醒醒醒醒醒就是我自己其实还看过挺多代码的包括viewreactor然后我还看过angular一点插的时候我看过然后其实还有vscode然后vipad之类的
看的原因就多整多样了乱七八糟但是最开始也看得很吃力然后最后我是觉得还慢慢的还挺有收获的然后书里的这样几个步骤这几个步骤就包括说我最开始进来之后也是我给大家推荐的最开始进来之后你首先就是去你别看具体的代码你就是观察一下这个目录结构
我到现在都是这样子我要看一个新的框架的原码的时候我一进来首先是看它的目录结构看它的package.json我通过package.json我能分析出来入口在哪里比如说这个web app的入口我一看我就知道在这个lib的index里面以及我们能看出来它用到了哪一些工具用到了哪一些cool等等我都能从这里去看出来对吧
所以还挺重要的然后其次的话就是目录我分析出来哪些目录可能是我现在就必须要高度关注的哪些是比较次要的有一个基础的判断这件事情很重要所以我在看这些框架的时候我基本上都会第一时间看这个目录结构其次的话是切入点什么叫切入点呢比如说我们前面在分析然后我就从它入口开始我想要理解一下它启动之后
到底做了什么事情这是一种切入点再其次别人说我现在就想研究一下 Webpack 它是怎么递归的读入所有的 Modular这又是另外一种切入点我又可以沿着切入点去分析有了切入点之后看资料不太建议一上来就骂
网上就很大部分的东西比如说reactor或者view大部分的东西都有无数人在写这种代表分析的文章所以就你就看资料呗但是看完之后不要看完之后就结束了那样子吸收起来的东西可能还挺少的看完之后要做的事情就应该是分析那个关键流程就是我看完之后我可能很多细节我都不记得但是关键的几个步骤你要梳理出来
就梳理出来的结果就好像我前面画的这个流程图一样这个流程图里面有大部分的细节我都丢失了但是我把我自己觉得重要的几个步骤全部都画下来这这张图当时还是我一边看一边画的最后美画一下然后发到文章上面的对这个对这个关键流程也很重要你要把那个关键流程画出来然后那个
分析出来然后把它划成印单图有了这个关键流程之后理解每一个关键流程的步骤之后你再去深入的观察每一个细节每一个细节的一些句报过说可能分支条件我们前面说要忽略分支条件但是一旦你有对这件事情有一个基本理解之后你就应该开始去理解这些分支条件理解每一个步骤的
每一个每一韩语句的价值然后在其次的话就是我觉得也很重要就是总结你就算总结出来只是一个笔记只是给自己看了也总好过没有你要是没有我我之前就在这种之前每次看完之后我就跳过了句也没也没沉淀下什么所以我到现在之前比如和react的代码我知道有这么回事但是很多细节我都忘了
所以其实总结还挺重要的主要是给自己留下一线东西那天要用到的时候翻一下原来是这样子我知道这就是我觉得你在看圆码的时候挺有用的一个步骤然后再其次的话有一些最佳时间不一个一个念了包括说沿着前面那一个流程图前面这六个步骤的流程图
沿着这一个流程途你在执行的过程中你还可以关注这一些点就包括说抓大犯晓球就忽略细节抓住主干然后随时总结随时记录然后目标明确这球就是一个拆出一个切入点然后这切入点必须是足够的合适可能是很小也可能很大Anyway根据你的状态根据你当前所在的阶段去选择一个具体的目标然后
就是你要研究的东西就是这一个目标其他的所有的分子逻辑你可以记下来但是现在的五用关注有一个前目标然后沿着这个前目标去做可能会更坏出结果不知道对大家有没有用然后我的要分享内容就差不多了然后前面列的一些图列的一些文章都在这里都是公众号里面的都可以随便去翻或者在我支付上面都有
我觉得如果你要去学外配的话应该是看这几篇文章应该是能有所帮助对然后有兴趣可以直接扫这张图吧这个二维码最后我是范文杰然后我其实是一个不太喜欢说话的人但是我很喜欢吃海鲜有机会一起吃饭